cuántos de vosotros aquí sois capaces de
hacer uno de estos
bastante gente joven bueno a lo mejor me
pasa un poco con lo fácil vamos a
ponerle un poquito más difícil no ver a
uno de estos
[ __ ] una persona 2 los unicornios son
jodidos no pasa nada es difícil
a lo mejor me pasa un poco esta vez
vamos a volver un poquito atrás vale
vamos a volver a vamos empezar por el
principio en realidad cuántos de
vosotros sois capaces de hacer uno de
estos
un folio en blanco si alguna gente
en horabuena haya habido que fabricar
papel en casa es un joven maravilloso
enhorabuena mi más sincera enhorabuena
para los que hayas levantado la mano
quizás la siguiente pregunta es también
os hacéis vuestros propios lápices si no
y ya quizás yo que sé vuestros propios
tostadores no bueno por cierto este es
el tostador de tomás white es que tiene
una charla antes maravillosa sobre lo
difícil que es hacer una un
electrodoméstico de uso común por uno
mismo empezando de cero yo recomiendo
que veáis todas las herramientas que he
mencionado aquí son parte del legado
tecnológico de la humanidad requieren de
una grandísima intersección de muchas
tecnologías fabricación transporte
extracción de recursos diseño por
ordenador y además también de que haya
una sociedad entera que permita que se
construyan pero ni un ser humano quizás
salvo thomas es capaz de hacer una de
ellas
esta paradoja ya la planteó en el año 73
arthur clarke y dijo algo como esto es
una de sus leyes por cierto no hay que
confundir las con las leyes de asimov
dijo cualquier tecnología
suficientemente avanzada es
indistinguible de la magia a milos los
casos que os he puesto me recuerdan un
poco a un buen truco de magia porque
son simples en primera apariencia aunque
en realidad son asombrosos y nadie salvo
el mago sabe cómo funcionan
yo creo que arthur tenía una visión un
poco romántica de la tecnología como
muchos de los que estamos aquí yo creo
que él soñaba con un mundo en el que la
tecnología estuviese tan integrada y de
forma tan natural en nuestra vida que ni
siquiera nos daríamos cuenta de que está
ahí de hecho por eso no tendríamos que
preocuparnos sobre cómo la tecnología
funcionase
esto es algo que a día de hoy ya está
pasando mucha gente intenta llevarnos a
ese punto y me atrevería a decir que hay
muchas tecnologías que ya son
indistinguibles de la magia incluyendo
quizás los lápices los tostadores y los
folios así que cuando grandes gurús y
empresas nos intentan vender esta esta
idea de convertirlo lo asombroso en
rutinario probablemente para vender más
pues a mí me salta un poco una alarma no
de hecho creo que es un gran problema
porque veréis nosotros no llegamos a la
luna conformándonos con los rutinarios
y sintiendo la necesidad de entender qué
es lo que nos rodea y mucho menos sin
tomar una actitud proactiva frente al
progreso y eso es exactamente a lo que
nos estamos acostumbrando a día de hoy y
como decía es un problema para mí es uno
de los grandes problemas de nuestra
sociedad os voy a explicar por qué
veréis pensando en todo esto de la magia
y la tecnología se me ocurrió que quizás
uno de los grandes magos del siglo 20
era steve jobs pero no por lo que mucha
gente piensa esto de que fue el único
capaz de convencer a la gente de que
apple crear una empresa privada era la
única capaz de hacer un dispositivo como
el iphone a pesar de que toda la
tecnología que está dentro del iphone
había sido desarrollada en eeuu y en
otros lugares con financiación pública
no yo creo que el gran truco de steve es
uno que sacó casi al final de su carrera
fue como su último as en la manga
la interfaz natural de usuario la
capacidad de interactuar con nuestras
máquinas a través de los gestos y
sonidos naturales del cuerpo ya le diré
pero danny de qué estás hablando esto
que tiene que ver con la magia bueno
pues yo creo que si hago bien mi trabajo
y espero estaba haciéndolo y al final
del día vais a estar de acuerdo conmigo
en que esto tiene mucho que ver con la
magia de hecho si hago muy muy muy bien
mi trabajo mañana vais a tener una
relación personal con vuestros
dispositivos completamente diferente a
la que tenéis hoy pero veo que pasará
algo como esto os levantáis por la
mañana iréis a mirar el periódico como
todos los días y desbloquear 'aces'
vuestro teléfono con la tecnología de
reconocimiento facial y de repente os
asaltara la duda y diréis esperan no sé
nada sobre tecnología de reconocimiento
facial pero no pasa nada porque internet
es una gran fuente de conocimiento así
que os metéis a buscar y veréis que la
tecnología fue desarrollada en torno al
65 por dos pioneros helen chan y wood y
bledsoe que habían sido financiados por
alguna agencia de inteligencia americana
aún no se sabe cuál para
para automatizar la toma de datos
biométricos de la cara en aquel momento
por cierto los ordenadores eran tan poco
potentes que se necesitaba un operario
para dar estos datos de forma manual al
ordenador 40 años después en el face
recognition cha lens de 2006 se había
llegado a la conclusión de que gracias a
nuevas tecnologías como las cámaras de
infrarrojos o las fotografías de
altísima resolución los algoritmos ya
eran mil veces mejores de lo que lo
habían sido sólo una década atrás y ya
superaban a los humanos es decir en 40
años habíamos perdido ante las máquinas
en una de las capacidades que
consideramos una de las claves de la
cognición humana y que además pensamos
que tiene un origen genético
diferenciado la capacidad de reconocer
caras pero bueno lo que se está mirando
en internet mañana por la mañana dio
seis cuentas domingo que vais en el arte
de comer a casa de los suegros no mentes
decir madre mía voy a llegar tarde me
todo el gps a ver cómo puedo llegar
antes al destino que quiero llegar y de
nuevos vuelve a saltar la duda no sé
nada sobre el gps cómo funciona esta
tecnología así que de nuevo está en
bullas en el océano de conocimiento que
es internet y descubrir es que la
tecnología se basa en una
de satélites de unos 30 satélites que
están constantemente encima de nosotros
habilitada literalmente por la misma
tecnología que nos llevó a la luna y
cuyo único objetivo es decirle a tu
teléfono o darle a tu teléfono la
capacidad de triangular sé a sí mismo
sobre la superficie de la tierra y no al
revés como muchos piensan también
descubriréis que la tecnología tiene un
origen militar y no civil y que solo
pasó a ser civil en el año 83 gracias a
la decisión de ronald reagan después del
accidente del korean airlines 007 que
fue derribado por dos mil soviéticos al
distanciarse de su rumbo
bueno y sinceramente una vez que estáis
aquí pues ya vais a estar en wikipedia
mirando artículos encadenando artículos
como si no fuera a ver un mañana y nadie
va a llegar a comer y bueno pues os vais
a quedar toda la tarde ahí mirando cosas
en wikipedia ver hasta dónde podemos
llegar
para los que sí que consigáis llegar a
comer a vuestra casa de vuestro suelo de
vuestros suegros os doy la enhorabuena
pero la realidad es que la razón por la
que habéis podido hacer eso es gracias a
la interfaz de usuario gracias a toda la
funcionalidad que condensa la interfaz
pero también gracias a toda la cantidad
ingente de conocimiento que deja detrás
de esa apariencia de simplicidad pero
todo el mundo sabe que a día de hoy el
conocimiento es lo más importante de
todo verdad pues no falso
lo importante es que billy aquí sea
capaz de tuitear sobre el tema plan ismo
o sobre si la tierra tiene o no seis mil
años de antigüedad con el menor número
de pulsaciones de sus pulgares
utilizando para ello el dispositivo o la
herramienta más potente jamás creada por
ese grupo de simios que llamamos
humanidad sin pararse a pensar ni un
minuto en si esas dos cosas tienen algo
que ver
esto es a lo que yo llamo un gran truco
de magia
bueno llegados a este punto de decir que
no tengo absolutamente nada en contra
del diseñador de interfaces de usuario
si alguno en la sala no tengo nada en
contra de vosotros de hecho creo que
hacéis maravillosamente vuestro trabajo
y creo que la interfaz de usuario es
algo que va a existir siempre ha
existido siempre y si siempre existirá
empezó cuando empezamos a utilizar la
tecnología para interactuar con el mundo
natural y bueno pues ha pasado desde los
relojes de sol hasta el mecanismo de
anticitera que también es muy conocido
hasta siri no entonces cuál es el
problema pues el problema está en de
nuevo en la frase de clark cualquier
tecnología suficientemente avanzada es
indistinguible de la magia
esta frase hace una equivalencia entre
el pensamiento científico basado en la
razón y la evidencia y el pensamiento
mágico basado en la creencia si no somos
capaces de distinguir entre ambas cosas
entonces no hay nada que evite que
acabamos discutiendo sobre si debemos
creer o no en el cambio climático o es
la razón por la que a lo largo de la
historia mucha gente ha intentado
demostrar la existencia de dios
la segunda parte del problema es un
poquito más más práctica y yo creo que
carl sagan que para mí es uno de los
mejores divulgadores del siglo 20 lo
puso mejor en una de sus célebres frases
vivimos una sociedad dependiente de la
ciencia y la tecnología en la que apenas
nadie sabe nada sobre ciencia y
tecnología la razón por la que nadie
sabe nada sobre ciencia y tecnología es
que las tecnologías a las que nos
exponemos nuestras tecnologías de
consumo están hechas para evitar que nos
tengamos que hacer una sola pregunta
desde los lápices hasta los iphones y no
hay mayor paradoja que la de la interfaz
de usuario
veréis la segunda parte de la frase de
sagan es un poquito es un poquito más
oscura y no suele aparecer que es que
esto es una receta para él para el
desastre claro es una receta para el
desastre porque si nunca debemos
hacernos preguntas sobre cómo funcionan
las cosas entonces bueno para que
necesitamos saber si toda la tecnología
que utilizamos funciona como por arte de
magia porque necesitamos hacernos
preguntas más aún igual que cuando un
mago nos hace un truco de magia
realmente queremos saber qué hay detrás
del truco o queremos conformarnos
conformarnos con vivir en la creencia de
que eso ha sido magia bueno pues esta
parte de la frase de salgan desde algo
de lo que mucha gente habla a día de hoy
y en concreto uno de los mejores
ejemplos es calcio nil que tiene un
libro maravilloso que se llama armas de
destrucción matemática algunos lo
conoceréis es muy bueno
y ella habla de este problema en él
desde el punto de vista de los
algoritmos los algoritmos invisibles que
nos rodean a día de hoy y que cada vez
tienen mayor impacto en nuestra vida
igual que la ciencia y la tecnología
cuando cuanto mayor es los sectores de
la población a los que afectan estas
tecnologías los problemas se vuelven
menos técnicos y más éticos y estos
problemas de los que habla casi no se
van a resolver si nos escondemos detrás
de nuestras pantallas dejando al otro
lado la curiosidad de hecho casi habla
mucho de los problemas relacionados con
los espacios de decisión cuando una
tecnología afecta a una cierta cantidad
de la población aquellos que están en el
espacio decisión suelen venir de la
intersección entre conocedores sobre una
tecnología y aquellos que toman
decisiones pero cuanto más grande es el
círculo de las personas a las que afecta
una cierta tecnología más pequeño es en
comparación el espacio donde se toman
las decisiones y si no estamos en esos
espacios de tomadores de decisiones
entonces que evita que se generen sesgos
en los algoritmos que predicen quién
tiene más probabilidad de cometer un
crimen como ocurre ya en chicago en eeuu
o como sabemos si las legislaciones
sobre la línea la experimentación sobre
la línea germinal humana son correctas
este caso ha sido muy famoso
recientemente por en china y ha sido
habilitado por la tecnología crisis
percas 9 o peor aun qué pasa cuando la
intersección entre esos dos sectores ni
siquiera existe como pasó con facebook
cuando salió a la palestra en el
congreso de eeuu y parece que nadie sabe
nadie sabía nada de lo que hacía
facebook incluso peor aún qué pasa
cuando la gente que dice saber sobre
tecnologías pones lights como estas y
lanza bases words como si fuesen
caramelos
pues esto es un problema y yo no tengo
la solución pero sí tengo una receta yo
creo que las recetas que funcionan bien
o que han funcionado antes son las que
las que suelen funcionar mejor
pero siempre viene siempre viene bien
recordarlas un poco así que son tres
puntos muy sencillos el primero dejarnos
guiar por nuestra curiosidad como ha
dicho mario despertarla y dejarnos guiar
por ella el segundo abandonar la
intuición de lo corriente la ciencia
está hecha para desafiar nuestros
sentidos no significa que las respuestas
que sean incorrectas y finalmente
confiar en nuestros divulgadores debemos
de reclamar como sociedad divulgadores
no charlatanes y además que las empresas
tecnólogos científicos nos den las
herramientas no sólo para poder divisar
el futuro sino para poder tomar
decisiones sobre él
yo creo que si seguimos estos 3 pasos
muy muy muy sencillos la próxima vez que
algo nos parezca magia queremos
averiguar el truco que hay detrás
gracias
[Aplausos]